our scripture of the day Colossians 3:23
whatever you do work heartily as for the
Lord and not men walter Chrysler said I
feel sorry for the person who can't get
genuinely excited about his work not
only will he never be satisfied but he
will never achieve anything worthwhile
well there you go
you know you need to be able to you got
bad days at work everybody's got bad
days at work sometimes you're tired
sometimes you're sick sometimes you're
sick and tired but overall you need to
really do be in a situation where you do
love what you're doing
if you can't genuinely get excited I get
excited when I come down here every day
to do this show to run this business to
hang out with these people I was telling
our Stephanie this morning I'm we're at
709 people now on our team and I was
telling them I'm just grateful because I
go into these meetings and I'm sitting
with these people and I'm kind of the
old guy now I mean I'm 57 and got off
most the people work here like
Millennials and so I'm sitting in these
meetings and these people aren't just
smart and they care deeply about you our
customer our listener they really do
care they actually genuinely get excited
what walter Chrysler said and it's fun
it's fun and I tell our team all the
time listen when when it quits being fun
go work someplace else
find something to do now again I'm not
talking about a bad season everybody
goes through a bad season where you've
got different times and things going on
in your personal life or you just get
you just kind of get tired you get run
down your paint gets empty everybody has
some of that I've got some of that
sometimes now and I have a calling on me
and I still get burnt up sometimes so
you know that's the deal but but for
goodness sakes be fired up be genuinely
excited about what you're doing whatever
you do work hard alee
as for the Lord and not for men act like
you work for God work like you work for
God cause you do do your work as if he
was your boss cuz he is yeah I mean what
would you your loving Heavenly Father
lord help me to do this show in a way
that makes you smile one of our prayers
before I come on the air every day yeah
I want us to make you smile by the level
of excellence the level of genuine
concern genuine excitement genuine
caring that occurs and don't you meet
people that act like you're their
customer you ever go into a restaurant
and they don't care Oh God that makes
you so mad didn't you ever go into a
place where there was supposed to be
quote waiting on you unquote and you
can't find someone to take your money oh
these people that are mailing it in
you're not talking about they don't care
and then when that place goes broke they
go oh well the economy the economy has
anything to do with it you didn't care
you can't care i want your sandwich shop
you didn't care i want your ice cream
store you can care i want your shoe
store and even care and enough people do
that they don't care if you go broke the
economy has a way of purging people that
don't care but you know in the victim
you're not a victim you're a victim of
the fact that you don't care bring it
work while you're at work unless you
work on the social media team you should
not be on facebook when you're at work
that's stealing when you're doing
something on your part of it for your
personal life while your boss is paying
you that's stealing you're supposed to
be working and here's what's weird
that's so unusual that if you work while
you're at work people will notice the
people that don't want to work while
they're at work won't like you because
you're not one of the bombs you know
you're making this all look
why by working if that makes you look
bad you need to reevaluate you not me
making us look bad
take it easy man Nani taking it easy I
got too much to do not gonna be taking
it easy not gonna be caught taking it
easy and don't you either don't settle
don't settle work while you're at work
when you're home be home don't work yeah
we have trouble being present we got one
foot stupid smartphones got us pulled in
14 different directions lay that thing
down work while you're at work when
you're at home be at home some novel
idea